janina schön und abend hier aus kiew
tatsächlich ist es mal für ein paar
stunden ruhiger in dieser stadt in der
wir so viele sie reden so viele bomben
so viel artillerie gehört haben in den
vergangenen tagen und das macht
zumindest vom gefühl her etwas hoffnung
hoffnung darauf das ist vielleicht doch
noch eine irgendwie geartete
diplomatische lösung geben könnte ich
würde euch mal beschreiben wie das
aussieht in kiel gibt es nicht nur eine
frontlinie sondern natürlich auch
diplomatische gespräche politiker
treffen sich an geheimen orten in
atombunker sie wechseln die orte um
darüber zu sprechen wie die zukunft
einer ukraine aussehen könnte das sind
alles geheimgespräche ich habe versucht
mit verschiedenen quellen heute darüber
zu sprechen welche szenarien welche
auswege ist aus dieser krise geben
könnte der erste das wäre tatsächlich
eine aufgabe der ukraine also bloß
selensky würde in den nächsten tagen zu
dem schluss kommen dass die militärische
übermacht russlands egal wie heldenhaft
sich die ukrainische soldaten
verteidigen zu groß ist tatsächlich gibt
es hinweise darauf dass immer weiteres
militär insbesondere hier richtung kiew
gebracht wird das schwereres gerät in
richtung der hauptstadt kommt und dass
das dann bedeuten könnte dass es
tausende zehntausende möglicherweise
hunderttausende tote geben könnte
dennoch könnte selensky wenn er in den
nächsten tagen verhandelt versuchen den
preis nach oben zu drücken den preis der
aufgabe das würde bedeuten er müsste
darüber sprechen was mit dem osten
passiert wäre das wirklich eine
komplette unabhängigkeit was passiert
mit diesen gebieten dann müsste er über
die krim sprechen wladimir putin will
dass die kim akzeptiert wird als
russisch und er müsste über eine
demilitarisierung sprechen das problem
für seal entgegen dem fall wie mir viele
berater und regierungsvertreter gesagt
haben ist dass er glaubt dass viele
glauben dass das in der bevölkerung
insbesondere moment nicht durchsetzbar
ist weil die bevölkerung so geschlossen
steht und so patriotisch steht dass
viele sagen wir wollen uns unser land
nicht nehmen lassen die zweite option
diese lenski oder die das land hat das
wäre tatsächlich deckt weitere krieg der
kampf da sagen diejenigen die diese
option befürworten unser militär ist
viel besser als gedacht wir erleben ein
riesiges chaos in der russischen armee
wie erleben dass ein general bereits
umgekommen ist wir erleben auch durch
den druck der waffen durch die druck der
waffenlieferung aus dem westen dass wir
russland aufhalten können bei diesem
szenario geht es nicht darum dass man
glaubt dass man das ende diese schlacht
so muss man es nennen gewinnen kann
sondern es geht darum zeit zu gewinnen
druck auszuüben und dafür zu sorgen dass
putin zu hause weiter unter druck gerät
diejenigen die dieses szenario
befürworten sagen das erste szenario
können wir nicht machen weil putin dann
gewonnen hätte weil putin dann
weitergeht weil putin nicht aufhören
würde wenn wir das erste szenario machen
und uns sozusagen mehr oder weniger
ergeben dann wäre das ganze erst der
anfang und wir kämpfen hier für ganz
europa das sind die beiden szenarien die
theoretisch möglich sind über die hier
in kiew heftig diskutiert wird in
geheimgesprächen ingelheim atombunker
und natürlich insbesondere mit blöde
mütze lens gehen
herr ischinger mit blick auf ihre
diplomatische erfahrung auch als
früherer chef der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz würde ich sie gerne
fragen welches szenario ist denn denkbar
oder gibt es noch ein anderes szenario
wo sie sagen so können der krieg endet
ich denke zurzeit ist auch nach dem was
wir gerade von uns haben wir gehört
haben der ausgang die die entwicklung in
den kommenden tagen und wochen völlig
unklar es kann sein dass die
ukrainischen kräfte sich so lange halten
können dass tatsächlich
nicht nur residenz selensky
gezwungen ist über kompromissformel
nachzudenken sondern das umgekehrt auch
die russische führung gezwungen sein
wird über reduzierungen ihrer bisherigen
maximalforderungen nachzudenken und und
das etwas zu sagen verbal zu
deeskalieren aber dass sie mich dazu
folgendes sagen das geht alles nur wenn
wir die gesprächskanäle wenn wir spricht
die usa gegenüber der russischen
föderation wir die bundesrepublik
deutschland die bundesregierung
gegenüber der russischen regierung und
andere
beteiligten mächte und organisationen
wenn wir die gesprächskanäle nach moskau
offen halten es ist wichtig dass der
amerikanische generalstabschef mit
seinem russischen kollegen redet um
missverständnisse und fehleinschätzungen
zu verhindern niemandem in der ukraine
ist gedient wenn dieser konflikt egal
aus welchem grund plötzlich jenseits der
ukraine eskaliert das ist doch für uns
die entscheidende aufgabe wie können wir
dafür sorgen dass dies nicht zu einem
raschen sieg dieses und aalen russischen
vorgehens führt aber gleichzeitig
verhindern dass das zu einem
europäischen oder globalen flächenbrand
wird dass die entscheidende aufgabe wie
der ausgang sein wird kann ich im auge
wer sagen aber ich bin der meinung wir
müssen mit der russischen regierung
selbst wenn es
wenn es uns wütend macht selbst wenn es
massive kritik wir müssen diese
gesprächskanäle offen halten denn mit
wem wollen wir den wandel mit wem soll
series getrennt verhandeln wenn dich mit
denen sie in moskau im augenblick wie in
habe der macht sind
die gesprächskanäle offen oder ist es
schon eigentlich 14er deeskaliert naja
also erstmal hoffe ich dass alle hören
was wolfgang ischinger einfordert weil
das ja was mit klugheit und besonnenheit
zu tun hat und in einem so emotionalen
auch von bildern getriebenen konflikt wo
menschen sozusagen bei laufender kamera
in die luft gepumpt werden wo eine
eskalation der des krieges der worte zu
verzeichnen waren letzte woche ist es
keineswegs selbstverständlich also
insofern hoffentlich bleibt dieser
diplomatische kanal offene es essentiell
ich glaube auch dass man mit den
vokabeln
gewinnen und verlieren sieg und
niederlage wird lernen müssen neue
umzugehen also was gibt es für die
ukraine noch zu gewinnen stell dich mal
als frage also dass es so bleibt wie es
vorher war ist ein unerreichbares ziel
angesichts der dominanz von putin auf
putins seite sieht es anders aus putin
hat das gefühl gewinnen können in den
letzten tagen und wochen auch wenn er
sich die rede von oder das interview von
annalena baerbock heute transkribieren
lässt von seinem botschafter dass er den
westen da hat wo er ihn haben will also
wir stehen geschlossen zueinander wir
setzen auf sanktionen die sanktionen
sind so mittel hart über die härte den
härtegrad der sanktionen gibt es viele
debatten
wir hängen es sozusagen wir sitzen in
der falle der abhängigkeit das alles mit
putin er vorher antizipiert haben und
deshalb ist er derjenige der auch auf
dem diplomatischen parkett im moment die
stärkere position hat also mein bild
dafür wäre wenn es bin gespannt ob das
teilen würde würden wir das auf einem
schachbrett sehen und ich darf mal ganz
kurz daran erinnern dass schach im
prinzip ein kriegsspiel ist wenn es auf
einem schachbrett sehen hält putin nicht
nur die ukraine sondern den westen im
moment im schach und wir sagen aber wir
haben ihm aber an bauern wird geschlagen
mit unseren sanktionen und das macht mir
schon sorge dass nicht nur die
militärische auseinandersetzung
asynchron ist sondern auch die
diplomatische da sitzt ein starker
herrscher am tisch ein diktator ein
mensch der auf menschenrechte nicht
besonders viel wert legt und da sitzen
die führer die anführer einer westlichen
wertegemeinschaft mit am tisch die immer
zum glück die westlichen werte
hochhalten dadurch aber am tisch
schwächer wirken müssen und das finde
ich im diplomatischen
aus diplomatischen auseinandersetzung in
eine situation die mit sorge erfüllt
weil man an dinge wie das ausgeht wenn
man aus dem lachen nicht mehr rauskommt
leute wolfgang ischinger claus strunz
werben ja dafür für die diplomatie und
für das gespräch wenn du auch als
bürgerin die diese bilder ansieht
verstehst du dann auch dass viele auch
in der debatte von emotionen
überschwemmt sind und eigentlich nur
noch fordern noch härtere sanktion noch
mehr militär ja natürlich die bilder die
wir tagtäglich sehen mit dem
konfrontiert werden die sind schrecklich
und man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
dass es so etwas heutzutage noch gibt
und das zerreißt einem das herz wenn man
das sieht und natürlich kann man
verstehen dass es viele jetzt gibt die
emotional am liebsten handeln würden und
aber klar natürlich schließlich auch dem
dann in dem moment an das bringt uns
natürlich nur kurzfristig weiter
langfristig gesehen wäre es natürlich
toll wenn man sich an einen tisch setzen
könnte und das ganze aus diskutieren
könnte besprechen könnte verhandeln
könnte aber wir reden halt hier nicht
über vernünftige erwachsene menschen
sondern über putin und ich glaube putin
wird das so weiter machen bis er selbst
mal getroffen wird und damit meine ich
jetzt nicht mit militärischer kraft
sondern ich meine tatsächlich die
sanktionen die jetzt getroffen werden
die gemacht werden wer hat im moment wer
muss im moment dafür zahlen die
bevölkerung von russland putin ist es
doch egal ob es im supermarkt noch
nudeln gibt oder nicht das ist eben doch
egal also ich glaub schon dass die
sanktionen für mich als bürgerin als
laie kann ich nur sagen
es wird ein grund dafür geben dass
deswegen machen die menschen diesen job
in der deutschen politik aber nicht
wundert es schon sehr dass man erst auf
die bevölkerung auch in russland
tatsächlich jetzt geht und nicht ihnen
die eier packt paul das war sehr hart
von schulen oder ausgedrückt haben die
eier park nein es war
ja also ich glaube er versteht kann
andere sprache welche sprache versteht
vielleicht mehr putin paul
wenn es so einfach wäre wenn man es
wirklich sagen könnte dann könnten wir
klarer analysieren was wir tatsächlich
tun müssen aber ich glaube tatsächlich
dass wir zu schwach waren in den
vergangenen jahren und dass wir in
gewisser weise auch jetzt noch zu
schwach sind in unserer antwort denn ich
halte es für problematisch dass die usa
wieder vorn geprescht ist und wir nicht
hinterherkommen bei der frage was ein
embargo angeht bei öl und gas jetzt kann
man natürlich darüber sprechen dass uns
das vor größere probleme gestellt
und sicherlich muss man dringend darüber
nachdenken was es für menschen bedeutet
die
eben weniger verdienen und
probleme bekommen an der tanksäule das
sind ganz ganz wichtige themen aber
nichtsdestotrotz bleibt ja das gefühl
dass wir weiterhin gas beziehen und öl
von einem mann der hier in dieser stadt
nur zehn kilometer von diesem ort wo ich
gerade bin und wo ich war in ihre pin in
vororten raketen auf menschen runter
regnen lässt auf zivilisten auf familien
auf kinder auf frauen der streumunition
einsetzt der ganz klar oder die jetzt
untersucht werden
kriegsverbrechen begeht und wir
weiterhin dort geld hin schicken und das
ist eine sache mit der ich mich einfach
nicht abfinden möchte und ich fand dort
heute auch in dem interview anna lena
berger hat man angemerkt dass sie sehr
emotional war dass sie in dem thema auch
sehr drin ist sie hat ja schon vor
jahren gesagt dass nord stream 2
gestoppt werden müsse sie war da sehr
viel klarer als die spd und dennoch ist
sie jetzt in einer regierung die das
eben nicht will olaf scholz sagt wir
sind davon zu abhängig christian lindner
will es nicht und sie entweder will sie
es tatsächlich nicht oder sie muss diese
position mit verbinden und das
stimmt mich dann schon
ja und da spielt natürlich auch eine
emotionalität eine rolle wenn man jetzt
seit vielen wochen hier ist als
kriegsberichterstatter und dieses leid
sieht dann geht einem das natürlich
näher das kann ich gar nicht
anders beschreiben und wenn man dann
menschen sieht die nichts mehr haben die
vor allem zusammenbrechen und dann im
nächsten satz sein aber warum macht der
westen das warum kauft ihr weiter gas
dann so schwer darauf eine antwort zu
geben herr ischinger die frage warum
macht der westen das müssen wir hier
auch vielleicht mal auf die interessen
amerikas blicken palast am anfang
angesprochen dass amerika da mehr
vorprescht ist es denn nicht auch so
dass amerika auch mehr profitieren würde
bei umso stärker die ölpreise steigen
also die gaspreise energiepreise die
ölpreise amerika hat eine sehr starke
industrie gibt es da vielleicht auch
eigeninteressen bei amerika und javi so
reagiert der westen nicht wie kann man
das erklären
na ja zunächst einmal ist es natürlich
so dass diese amerikanische entscheidung
voll und gasimporte aus russland jetzt
abzuschneiden amerika relativ weniger
einschneidend schaden wird als dass er
fall sein würde wenn wir jetzt das
gleiche tun würden also bei uns wären
die folgen das muss man einfach sachlich
betrachtet
man muss sich die zahlen anschauen bei
uns wären die die die folgen
schwerwiegend dar so ich finde dass
amerika einen richtigen schritt
ergriffen hat selbst wenn der amerika
nicht so hart treffen wird wie das bei
uns der fall sein würde ich persönlich
würde es auch befürworten sein
nachfolger
müsse sicherheitskonferenz christoph
heusgen hat das jetzt und auch punkten
ich schließe mich dem an ich persönlich
würde es für richtig halten wenn wir
diesen schritt gehen würden aber ich
sehe natürlich welchen zwängen die
bundesregierung ausgesetzt ist das
gehalt wird groß sein wenn die
energiepreise in warschau steigen und
wenn wenn ihr manches dann aus kommt aus
der kontrolle gerät wenn ihr
arbeitsplätze verloren gehen und so weit
ist denn dann hinterher schuld das muss
man ich will aber noch ein anderer punkt
hinzufügen hören sie herr uns einmal hat
ja recht und das erst in verzweiflung
ist ist natürlich groß es gibt zwei wege
druck auf die russische führung zu
erhöhen der eine weg ist der weg den wir
jetzt gehen der weg über die stationen
der weg über bestimmte waffenlieferungen
die deutsche seite leider erst sehr spät
angefangen haben aber das ist so der
andere weg wäre der weg über inneren
druck aus russland heraus und hier sehe
ich ein bisher völlig ungetrübt das feld
nach allem was ich persönlich aus
eigenen gesprächen und telefonaten mit
russischen kollegen weiß ist dass zwar
die intellektuelle schicht in moskau
unsere verzweiflung
unsere besorgnisse über diesen
unprovozierten angriffe ich teilen aber
die breite
mehrheit in der russischen bevölkerung
ist der putin gino baganda zum opfer
gefallen und glaubt dass anscheinend bis
zum heutigen tag sein ich frage mich als
und ich bin die frage in der runde geben
ich bin gar nicht der fachmann für nicht
bei der arbeit wie so sind wir wie so
ist der westen wieso sind die usa wieso
ist die europäische union nicht in der
lage mit allem was wir haben an internet
möglichkeiten
ich würde mal sagen an
jedem einzelnen russen mehrfach am tag
klar zu machen dass sein präsident im
augenblick einen mörderischen krieg im
nachbarland beginnt und das ist
keineswegs so ist dass die ukrainischen
brüder und schwestern die russischen
komponieren und anna mit mit freude
empfangen sondern dass sie sich entgegen
stand das ist in moskau vielleicht
intellektuellen inzwischen klar aber es
ist im wind rauschen im land nicht klar
und ich glaube hier muss man ansetzen
und eine große
öffentlichkeitsarbeit kampagne starten
und jeder größten klar zu machen dass
ist das eigene land ist was ich hiermit
mit schande zu dritt und und und auf
jahrzehnte hinaus die russische ehre bis
mittel die glaube russen reagieren auf
solche punkte hoffentlich können wir die
nach russland ihn eintraten